hey what's going on spill burn it's time
for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday April 23rd 2018 what's going on
how are you
Asik oh and I'm actually recording this
on [ __ ] Wednesday April 25th case
you're listening to this in the future
you wanted to know what was going on
with me as far as my health goes now
notice I said as far as my health goes
instead of health-wise I learned in
vocab improvement back in high school
there's no such thing as the wiseguys
health-wise weather-wise you know that's
why I can never listen to come fly with
me hey Frank I know you connected but
that's improper grammar all right I'm
not attacking you or your heritage of
affect you from New Jersey or right you
overly sensitive so-and-so I'm just
saying that that's you know I don't know
who wrote that song okay so why don't
you scooby doo dee da da da boo over to
a [ __ ] dictionary and you you find me
weather-wise Francis
am I really trashing a dead [ __ ]
Frank Sinatra sorry I've almost lied and
tried to tell you I'm on cold medication
but I'll take cold medication cold
medication is for [ __ ] Millennials
all right and even if you're older and
you take it you're a millennial at heart
you can't deal with the fact that you
got yourself sick
you need to lay down get eight hours and
let your body [ __ ] go through it all
right the reason why your nose is
running this because it's trying to get
the virus how do you just let it happen
these [ __ ] [ __ ] I swear to god
man the amount of people that gave me
advice you know there's no cure for the
common cold but everybody thinks they
have one you know what zinc yeah I could
try some zinc shot a whiskey Joe my
manager told me he goes vitamin D
everybody thinks it's C vitamin D
unbelievable well the greatest managers
in the world and he also knows the cure
for a cold that we don't knew that just
[ __ ] with you Dave
let's get that out of the way Jesus
Christ this is just a cold that won't
quit this is the cold that's letting me
know that Mother Nature is regrouping
you know right now we're squeezing her
all right like the way Andre the Giant
was squeezing [ __ ] Hulk Hogan in that
documentary and they're lifting mother
nature's arm and they're dropping it
down they lift it up they're dropping it
down like oh my god the bad guy isn't
gonna win and at one point her arms just
gonna stay there and she's gonna start
shaking a [ __ ] blonde hair that was
always my favorite part when Hulk would
start coming back and he'd give him that
one big hit and then he'd walk around
the ring looking up and looking up at
the rafters just shaking his head it was
the best I watched that documentary like
three times and when when I watched that
that part of the fight with me we were
both laughing our asses off in a great
way like dates just some of the greatest
[ __ ] performers of all time and
professional wrestlers you know when I
was growing up right through the rock
and all all those guys like their
ability stone cold all of that their
ability to work a crowd it's just it's
second to none you know I got a buddy
mind still going like dude yeah but is
it like a fake fight you know is it but
isn't like a fake fight it's just like
how [ __ ] dumb are you
it's like yes it's entertainment they
they take [ __ ] Senate like 30 years
ago it's some guy cried all right the
greatest thing they ever did was say
that it was all arranged and all that
[ __ ] for the most part so then they
could actually talk about how [ __ ]
hurt they got when they actually were
doing these fake flights I did tell
bernzy that like fuzzy if you knew okay
we had a fake fight and I said I was
gonna pick you up and throw you across
the room and you're going to land on
your back
you know that would still hurt even
though you know we arranged that it was
gonna happen right physics is still in
play there no sorry I'm a little hot
here with this [ __ ] mics having a
problem with my recorder here Oh God
so I believe it or not I'm actually on
the other side of this thing I
completely lost my voice bye bye Sunday
and so I started gargling with a little
bit of apple cider vinegar and some salt
in there that kind of cleared me up a
little bit I'll do that [ __ ] but I'm not
going down to the [ __ ] drugstore even
though I did and I bought all this [ __ ]
and I just looked at the ingredients I'm
like I'm not putting this in my [ __ ]
body so basically what I kicked this
[ __ ] out of my [ __ ] liver so this
medicine can fool my [ __ ] nose that I
don't have a cold
I apologize dude foul stuff alien but I
got to do this because I'm gonna be
[ __ ] backed up on podcast cause I got
the Thursday well tomorrow I'm liking
that I Love Lucy sketch where they got
the chocolates coming down except it's
broadcasting I mean Christ I don't have
time for this [ __ ]
guess what the [ __ ] I watched yesterday
on the plane coming back actually went
up to Boston and I visited my family
back east and on by the way the [ __ ]
anger that is still in Massachusetts
it's not really with the younger kids
which kind of makes me happy yet a
little bit sad you know some point you
do have to let go of the anger but I
hope I hope all the characters are still
you know around but I was driving
through my my old neighborhood and Isis
cop direct and traffic and a little
[ __ ] three-way stop he tells this guy
to stop it evidently he didn't and the
cop starts flipping out and I'm like
[ __ ] two three cars down the line so
I I can't hear what the guys saying but
he is [ __ ] flailing his arms like
Earl Weaver right he manages the Orioles
about [ __ ] 40 years ago
sorry and I'm laughing my balls off a
[ __ ] angry is at this guy right
and then when he gets the guy to stop
and then the other key waves us to start
going like that's not enough for him he
walks up to the guys car and starts
screaming at him so I'm thinking maybe
this is some young punk with his radio
turned up and he's not listening to the
cop I show up it's like some old dude
with like white hair
this [ __ ] 8-foot cop is screaming at
him I don't know how you doing I would
not I would not have handled that well
if he came up to my window there's no
way I would have been like relax and
then I would have been you know in cuffs
because she can't tell a guy who's
flipping out and screaming at you to
[ __ ] relax I need to learn my rights
for those moments because I am a control
freak and I forget that I don't know how
to fight in those moments and I just
immediately go to go [ __ ] yourself and
then and then the ramification comes and
I am not prepared for
I actually got angry for that guy and
started drove past the cops saying all
the [ __ ] to the cop in my car to myself
as if I was that guy talking to that cop
a [ __ ] nuts is that or is that normal
is that something you do I just feel
like for me Jesus Christ I haven't been
this sick since I've been a dad which is
[ __ ] brutal to get this sick when
you're a dad because then you can't hug
your kid which is the worst I mean
that's what you have a kid for so you
can hug him right can lie about what you
did when you were a kid right that's
what you do I used to make my bed every
day I did all my homework I was never a
problem for my parents anyways I had a
[ __ ] amazing weekend so I got to work
the Ryman once again that's the third
time I've been there I did Vince
Vaughn's Nashville Comedy Festival in
2014 then I did it again in 2016 I taped
my last special there walk your way out
and then I got to do it one show Friday
one Saturday and they brought me a drum
kit and [ __ ] to play on
and I was so sick I couldn't play it
felt bad and I had a splitting [ __ ]
headache but the shows were really fun
and I actually I always hit that Jack's
BBQ next door and then I went to the
Woolworths they've got a Woolworths
outside with a [ __ ] lunch counter
like where they had like back in the day
during segregation or they're just like
only white people can sit here and get a
grilled cheese sandwich
God made everybody in His image but he
made us closer to his image and He loves
us just a little bit better because of
that we get to sit at this shine
encounter that arresting you on white
white white [ __ ] people got to go
around back so I sat down I got a
[ __ ] cheeseburger they're you know
taking pictures just I I went into
Woolworths like a white person going oh
my god I remember these things you know
I used to be able to buy [ __ ] a shirt
and then get a cheeseburger so I walked
in not realising the historical
magnitude of what I was walking into I
was just walking guys sell shirts here
nobody we don't we don't I walked right
up to the [ __ ] counter I was taking
pictures and [ __ ] and everybody thought
I was like some [ __ ] historian and I
wasn't I was as excited that had the
same emotional historical context to me
as if if I walked into a Jordan Marsh
do they have Jordan marshes anymore do
you remember all those all those defunct
super stores it's funny they were even
when they came out because they put out
the mom-and-pop businesses and then
eventually when you watch them get eaten
you lot you you ended up feeling bad for
them the place is like mammoth mark
remember mammoth Mart and a big woolly
mammoth child world got destroyed by
[ __ ] Toys R Us Lechmere they lost out
to the [ __ ] Best Buy's Radio Shack
there's still a few of them left over
you know what I mean they're like
[ __ ] old Nazis there's still a couple
you let them running around scurrying
around South America you know to me
trying to get a [ __ ] tan fitted with
the Regulus right well some of the other
ones that they used to have I can't even
remember anymore so logos Filene's
Jordan Marsh then Macy's just came alone
just [ __ ] them all up just [ __ ] him
all up
Bloomingdale's beat the [ __ ] out of
everybody and then you had all those
like stores you just heard about but you
know like Saks Fifth Avenue when I was a
little kid I they might have been one of
Boston but I think if you wanted to go
to Saks Fifth Avenue had to go to Fifth
Avenue in New York City and nobody
really [ __ ] knew all of the all of
that all of that designer [ __ ] that all
the kids wearing nowadays like and I was
like Mobile Alabama and they had like a
[ __ ] Louis Vuitton store they never
used to have that [ __ ] you know they
only had three series of the BMW the
three the five in the seven though they
also had the six if you couldn't afford
one of those go [ __ ] yourself they
didn't make it [ __ ] SUV I didn't
think I don't think they did they didn't
have a one series a two series of four
series you know just [ __ ] doing
anything they can that's like what
mercedes-benz drop they're not that
quality but they dropped it all the way
down where you could buy the was it the
190e the baby Benz they used to call it
no son you driving around a
mercedes-benz that cost the same amount
of money as a Monte Carlo right and you
were this Monte Carlo [ __ ] T Top Pot
dealin douche you know who would have
looked right in his Oldsmobile Cutlass
but instead you'd ride around this 190e
like you're [ __ ] sophisticated
everybody saw her right through you know
second he got out of the [ __ ] car
right no your personal belongings fall
in the [ __ ] grove you know some scale
to weigh your product I don't know I'm
talking about but when I was a kid all
the cool older guys the guys who like 25
which to me was a man he had a mustache
he had your own place
the chick was living with you and he
could [ __ ] her whenever you wanted you
know my ID is a 14 year old dude he
lives with her they can eat can [ __ ] her
whenever he wants to not realize it not
realizing like the [ __ ] that he was
probably looking at me envious of Miko
look at that [ __ ] orange headed
hairless faced [ __ ] loser over there
he's got it all ahead of him doesn't
have any credit card bills doesn't have
some broad living within a [ __ ] moaning
and complaining about where he leaves
his [ __ ] neon green [ __ ]
sunglasses anyways but what I was
looking at they were the coolest people
ever and then there was there was the
Buick Regal no Monte Carlo and the
Oldsmobile Cutlass and there with it
these two-door coupes and if you got the
[ __ ] T top you know I loved I loved
the guy that went down at the [ __ ]
art whatever they whatever auto parts
store that the auto zones
ate all up you go down there and I
remember people would get there they put
curb finders on them they cut T tops at
them they get the glass tinted the
[ __ ] headlights tinted all this
cheesy [ __ ] they'd get a custom license
plate on the front said like Mikey you
know and you were the [ __ ] man if you
actually had a CD player and ever that
was the big thing like you got it like
it was an external thing I remember this
guy I knew he had a [ __ ] Volkswagen
Scirocco which was I swear to God that
was the name of the car and he had this
[ __ ] CD player and it was like it was
like an external hard drive like you had
to plug this court in that then plugged
into the CD that was mounted on the
armrest between the two bucket seats and
if you even hiccup in the car the CD
skipped but it was still [ __ ] insane
and then of course you had to have your
radar detector for the [ __ ] state he
stood and all of that is gone you know
it back then if you got a cold you put a
little Vicks face
for rubbin your [ __ ] chest and that
was it now what do they got Jesus Christ
I mean if they can [ __ ] they can hold
off the HIV virus now you'd think that
they could [ __ ] you know do something
about the cold but you always pay a
price it's always a price to pay you
know he's always pay you know he's the
battered [ __ ] wife of your organs is
your [ __ ] liver liver always takes it
you know what I mean you [ __ ] up in
other areas and then you take your
medicine right
you're a scatterbrain lunatic you can't
get to sleep so you take some Tylenol PM
and who pays for it huh you're [ __ ]
liver how many times you're gonna have
your liver have to walked around with
its eyes looking down at your [ __ ] :
you know as the other [ __ ] organs are
going what happened I walked into the
ribs is he making light of domestic
violence yes I am I think that's the
problem with this country there needs to
be more domestic violence we actually
live in an era that someone wouldn't
even look at that even remotely is
[ __ ] absurd and in an era where
[ __ ] I can't say the word anymore
people unlike the the internet will just
take that clip and they try to get you
in trouble you know I mean everybody's
ratting everybody out like you know I
really looked at that [ __ ] Conor
McGregor thing what was that guy
videotaping it for and then he [ __ ]
puts it up on the [ __ ] Internet and
just gets this guy in all this [ __ ]
trouble
I'm not saying Conor McGregor was right
but like who's just [ __ ] out like I
would say I would have videotaped that
[ __ ] I mean just wow glad I wasn't on
that bus right you know I mean that
guy's the reason everybody on that bus
is making [ __ ] a zillion dollars
anyways isn't he can't every once in a
while throw a [ __ ] two-wheeler at a
goddamn bobby chick tear the [ __ ]
champ you know
you know get a little bit of leeway all
it takes is one [ __ ] douche with his
flip phone and all of a sudden he's down
there talking to the cops
I don't know talking about guess what
today is everybody
oh it's Game seven for the Boston Bruins
everybody's freaking out and all this
[ __ ] oh my god we have three games to
one who gives a [ __ ] all we got to do is
win tonight all you gotta do is win
tonight no one [ __ ] remembers so many
series that are three two one go to game
seven it happens all the [ __ ] time I
will say though as a Bruins fan if I see
I don't have to listen to one more
commentator tell me that it was a
stretch pass you know Jesus Christ had
Anderson has played so great for Toronto
I don't know why he does all that
flopping around
you literally skate by the guy wind
knocks him off his [ __ ] feet just
shameless shameless but I like the
[ __ ] Maple Leafs you know what I mean
despite their timidly cocky fans on
Twitter who said absolutely nothing and
now all of a sudden you know they're
like meerkats you know what I mean when
a [ __ ] Cobra comes around they all
sit there lunging at you and [ __ ]
talking all this [ __ ] as they back up
but they're not really gonna fight
they're trying to appear bigger than
they are I got no beef what's wrong you
guys went tonight congratulations I can
get past it I don't give a [ __ ] right I
know that we're a team of the future and
so you guys this would probably be the
beginning of a great rivalry that's what
we need God knows because the Canadians
are in the [ __ ] [ __ ] I have this
[ __ ] guy that like I can't go how the
[ __ ] I met him I was doing like a gig a
long time ago and he drove us there and
somebody got my phone number and this
[ __ ] [ __ ] every year during the
playoffs the Brewers so good when I was
[ __ ] douches so I finally I just
finally blocked his number like I don't
get this kids I got get it you [ __ ]
drove we do a couple of gigs I gotta
listen to your [ __ ] horseshit every
time we're doing bad there's so many
[ __ ] [ __ ] eSports fans like that
and after almost 20 years of voting a
cellphone I finally learned how to block
people I love it
let's [ __ ] love it it's just like you
know if somebody I used to work with to
this business [ __ ] I don't know what
the [ __ ] is deal was he [ __ ] started
calling me and emailing me yeah
block over you know what I mean it's
like you get to assassinate somebody
without having to kill him and deal with
the guilt you know and whatever in the
future when we're all just being watched
by robots and every last thing you do is
videotaped so you can't do anything
wrong I wonder if they'll have to switch
the commandments just so they can get
somebody in trouble because nobody can
do anything anymore
so rather than thou shalt not kill the
fifth commandment will be thou shalt not
block somebody on your cell phone
you shall not assassinate them digitally
I'm sorry did I just did I just float
out a perfect premise for the next Blade
Runner no I didn't I did not however
there was that movie that came out when
people had to take a test and if you
know when the world was overpopulated
those [ __ ] [ __ ] where the hell did
you get that idea god bless him she
don't I mean how about a tip of the cap
anyways sorry people understood a
[ __ ] I've just had a headache for so
[ __ ] I did buy some Bayer Aspirin I
did that celtics everybody how about
those boston celtics how about the hot
at the Boston Celtics and how about
those [ __ ] Milwaukee Bucks this is
the best they've been since back with
like Sidney Moncrief you know then they
got that white dude from [ __ ] the
Seattle Sonics with that [ __ ] was his
name Jack Sikma but I have to be honest
with you dude the basketball is so
[ __ ] awful that I'm watching then I
even play in hoop it looks like a
[ __ ] pickup game and an unbelievably
high level how many [ __ ] times can
you throw up a three with nobody
underneath
let me I don't understand that new
little semicircle there I gotta look
read up on it in the paint is it illegal
if you don't have the ball as an
offensive player to get under the
[ __ ] rim was the last time you saw a
center post up and put his hand in the
air and threw a couple up and under so
you know a little kevin mchale action a
little skyhook it's all [ __ ] gone
you just run down the core they'll pass
and then the guy just takes a
three-point I didn't go in or so he does
so and one [ __ ] to try to get around a
guy draw a foul it's [ __ ] it's
horrible I think I thought the entire
second quarter I don't think I saw one
pick and roll you know there's a reason
that they did that for [ __ ] close to
80 years it works I don't know why
everybody's trying to do this
Globetrotters [ __ ]
daddy pepper that I haven't said that I
love where we're going in the future I
just don't like the future of the game I
guess people got too big is that what it
was
I missed a bangin down low in the paint
you know and that [ __ ] old schoolyard
play where the guys leaning against you
leaning and you stepped out behind him
like you pulled his chair out he falls
down then they'd stand up and getting
each other's grills then a little
[ __ ] ref came up to that dicks was
trying to push him apart I miss all of
that I miss it man I miss the way you
smell I actually gotta be honest with
you I shut the game off because I was so
[ __ ] I cause I [ __ ] hate NBA hoop
I just hate basketball I just hate how
no lead is safe it's like you're up by
40 you go in the kitchen and then you
make a sandwich it's like the other team
follow the three-pointer this could tie
it up it's just like can there ever be
can you ever just have an easy win
I just felt myself getting ready to
throw something at the [ __ ] TV and I
get a kid now so I can't so I just shut
it off and I was just then I just
watched the score throughout the fourth
quarter and they wanted
like good I'm more of a hockey guy
obviously that haven't said that I you
know of course I have to edit some [ __ ]
for emphasis family tonight but I'll get
to watch most of the game it's only a
game seven you know I'm very excited for
this you gotta love a game stuff even if
your team was up to anyone who gives a
[ __ ] gotta love a game seven and here's
the deal is if we lose to Toronto that's
my team for the rest of the playoffs
because they haven't won since 67 and I
think it's a high time but they get anti
be cool to see Winnipeg get their first
one so those are my two teams
those are my onesie twosie alright so
there you go there's your [ __ ] Bruins
there's your NBA and NHL hayfever [ __ ]
talk for the goddamn week oh you know
what I forgot to [ __ ] mention like I
started to mention it but maybe I'll
mention it after I do a little LA I got
one read for this week alright but oh do
me on DS me on DS get in the [ __ ]
paint to do doo doo biondi's B undies
throw it down to his taint spin around
and [ __ ] dunk it stop throwing up
threes if you please it's [ __ ] boring
I feel like I'm at the [ __ ] YMCA
except people can't dunk you've heard me
talk about me undies and you know that
I'm a big believer in their product they
just sent me another bag of underwear
these guys got a stop it's just like I
don't have a bladder problem ok I get it
you guys make a lot of underwear I have
some and I like it you don't need to
send me some every [ __ ] month treat
me like your [ __ ] underwear [ __ ] on
the side they're perfect balance of
comfortable fit every month they have
new and exciting prints and they arrive
at your door in a fun bag the undies
uses lensing micro Modell modal in their
underwear
it's sustainably sourced naturally soft
fiber that starts with
Beachwood trees and ends with the most
amazing fabric you've ever experienced I
don't know why that is in the [ __ ]
copy at least in my copy my listeners
are not smart I'm not smart when you
start saying that your underwear is made
out of trees we start thinking about
getting splinters and our undercarriage
you know don't hear about [ __ ] fitzy
can't have kids he is [ __ ] underwear
I was being out of beechwood trees he
[ __ ] took him off too fast he stabbed
both his balls he's got no one he's got
no what she has left well because it ran
down his leg kid he listen to the
[ __ ] story the results have been
downright dreamy beyond these
adventurous prints and designs are all
limited editions yeah it's just I
wouldn't even take him out of the rap
you know who knows something somebody
might want to collect them like action
figures and new patterns are released
every few weeks on a rolling basis 100%
satisfaction guarantee guarantee me
undies guarantees you will love their
undies or your money back if you didn't
know what a guarantee was me undies has
a great offer for my listeners whatever
the [ __ ] else they gave us too for any
first-time purchasers when you purchase
any me undies you get 20% off and free
shipping the undies is so sure you'll
love their underwear they offer 100%
satisfaction guaranteed you already
[ __ ] said this if you don't love the
first pair you get a full refund that's
a no-brainer get 20% off a pair the most
comfortable undies you will ever put on
to get you 20% off your first pair of
free shipping whatever such a
satisfaction guarantee go to the undies
comm slash bar that's my undies comm
slash bar alright so I've teased it
twice let me see
Liverpool Football shed jewel what do
they play next I was on the plane and I
actually watched live Liverpool first
[ __ ] Roma and it was a [ __ ] it was a
blowout it was an awesome game Liverpool
went up 5-2 [ __ ] nothing Saturday
4:30 a.m.
I don't I just don't [ __ ] get how
this [ __ ] works they're playing Roma
isn't that like Rome that's the
Champions League semi-final leg two of
to aggregate two to five yeah they won
five to two so they got to play again on
May 2nd is that cuz they scored five
goals and roamers Roma scored - what's
the coincidence of that I just don't
understand it because they were up five
to nothing and then all of a sudden Rome
Roma scored a goal and then they scored
another one on a penalty kick and then
they were saying then the bouncers were
going nuts I'm like what is a [ __ ]
two minutes left way if I don't like to
get to lose this game
I think they're in some sort of
tournament that happens at the same time
that the Premiership is being played
it's weird like that's the Champions
League and I think Liverpool Chelsea
that's the premier Premier League right
they do it at the same somebody for the
love of God somebody over there in Great
Britain somewhere around the [ __ ]
world explain to me what's going on
because I actually really enjoyed the
[ __ ] game dude this guy holy [ __ ]
this Egyptian dude who kind of looks
like an Egyptian Judd Apatow most salla
this [ __ ] guy put on a goddamn clinic
first of all he used to play for Roma so
he scores a goal then he does this big
dramatic I'm not gonna celebrate you
know which was more annoying that if he
just celebrated cuz that he scored again
the first one was to like a fight it was
like a lot of it's like hockey what
[ __ ] top shelf corner on the far side
I believe with his left foot and then a
few minutes later whatever he comes back
down again and he just and that one that
was the first one was a [ __ ] blast
and the next one was nice soft touch
right up and over the [ __ ] guy the
goalkeeper I believe for his second goal
once again
start spraying getting on his knees and
[ __ ] kissing the ground and doing all
this [ __ ] like he's not gonna have a
threesome after the [ __ ] game you
know what I mean like he's gonna go
[ __ ] rescue a cat out of a tree so
like to take your junk out and shake it
in the other team's face you know you
want to and then he set up he had two
assists whatever they call the helpers
to [ __ ] crumpets I don't know what
the [ __ ] they call you guy had like four
points if he was playing hockey two
goals two assists
it was incredible then there was this
other poor bastard I think he finally
scored a goal
he had a breakaway [ __ ] that up that he
was in when in hockey what would be
called the slot and he just [ __ ]
missed kicked it blasted it over the
[ __ ] net I think he spent more time
on his [ __ ] Mohawk than he did on his
[ __ ] learn how to shoot the ball into
the goddamn net but there was seven
goals it was like the kind of [ __ ]
soccer game that I yet could enjoy but I
was stuck on a plane and we had a
ridiculous headwind I was like I'm gonna
sit here and watch this [ __ ] thing
and I totally got into it by the way
Liverpool's [ __ ] coach his dentist
should be [ __ ] disbarred
he should have his license [ __ ]
revoked you know I'm sure it was the
coach's idea but if you got a [ __ ]
goat in and you don't get your fake
teeth whitened to that level Jesus
Christ he looked like the plant and
Little Shop of Horrors except he had
glasses on so anyways I was really into
it so I guess I kind of why is there so
much time between games though
oh no the next one is April 28th that's
it I'm gonna watch [ __ ] I'm gonna
support Liverpool I like the Beatles who
gives a [ __ ] right like I got time for
this [ __ ]
there's no way to watch it not all of a
sudden one I have a [ __ ] beer though
I will tell you that you know and I've
been [ __ ] Billy no fun Billy no vice
other than four hits a weed one night
which I immediately regretted cuz all
that does is make me sleepy and I'm
trying to become one with the world I
don't get munchies I just fall asleep
like a cat on a [ __ ] windowsill I
don't give a [ __ ] where I am I'm going
to sleep yeah
anyways let's get on with the questions
here I still haven't watched that MotoGP
I know that MOC MOC has wanted and there
was a big anticipation that him and uh
Valentino Rossi we're gonna be [ __ ]
donkey kicking each other about [ __ ]
two hundred kilometers but he just
[ __ ] blew by everybody by the second
turn I don't know I gotta watch it
though I [ __ ] love that sport though
okay emails for the week I might have to
do a little short podcast here everybody
my [ __ ] voice is bugging the [ __ ] out
of me alright Belgium hey Bill would you
consider to come back to Belgium in 2019
please keep us posted absolutely I would
I was only there for like 24 hours that
I loved it I was in Antwerp I believe
excuse me Oh disgusting sorry has to be
done it has to be done you gotta blow it
out I should have do a kids show sketch
about having a cold you know you just
have some up--it that's always [ __ ]
sick and then the kids can't [ __ ]
sail touch the thing cuz it's sick and
then you make the puppet act all sad cuz
it's lonely and then when the kids come
over cuz they feel bad for it he
chastised the hell out of them for
giving into the weak emotion of love and
you set him up for the real world
fish starter pack you know what I
downloaded one of their CDs their
harmonies are amazing the music it
doesn't quite grab me their incredible
[ __ ] musician but they just they
there's I don't know there's something
I'm gonna keep listening all right
you're talking about [ __ ] bed that
sold-out Madison Square Garden like 18
nights in a row or something so it's got
to be me on some level you know what I
mean
I look at fish the way I look at beyond
saint-like it's got to be me right I
have to be the person that's when
somebody fills up the [ __ ] Rose ball
you don't mean the second they say
they're gonna be there and you're like
yeah I don't get it then at some point
it's you it is you right
I don't know darris Billy Brett briefs
breaths I always say what I appreciate
well I appreciated the last fish suggest
fish suggested of starting with rift
it's a very specific album pretty palsy
of that guy who start you with rift it's
as if he wants to make it hard on you
know okay I like this guy I like the
other guy too they thought I was smart I
like this guy because he knows I'm
stupid all right yeah make it easy but
give me the answers you should download
hoist it's not he's saying it and as the
last guy suggested a live one then I'll
give you something fun to work with
again I love riffs but I also want you
to have a fair shot also story of ghost
is funky and Billy Billy breaths is fun
too
it was it Billy breathe I'm so dumb and
not to sound cliche but have you seen
Dead and company yet it's a really fun
show and definitely worth checking out
man yeah those hippy shows there's just
such a vibe of insincerity atom that I
can't handle from the crowd where
everybody's just trying to like I don't
know you know like what do you see a mom
and she's talking to a kid in public and
talking really loudly some cute
conversation and looking at you smiling
it's like will you shut the [ __ ] up
will you bring the volume down I get it
kids are cute it's not my kid you know I
don't care that the kitchen's counted to
five no no bitsy you have to sit here
you need to put this your
you're first okay and then they look at
you and smile is they do the
play-by-play of the kid putting a
[ __ ] marshmallow in its mouth I feel
like when you go to one of those hippy
things that people are doing that but
they're kind of doing it you know to
show like how everybody's you know this
is like how society should be man oh and
the [ __ ] the body odor I don't mean
like I mean the Cologne that they wear
whatever the [ __ ] it is just the the the
[ __ ] douche gumbo that's what I can't
handle when I'm there it's always
[ __ ] hot you know and everybody's
wearing a sundress it's just I don't
know I'm too much of a curmudgeon why I
think we bomb Syria oh good for you
help me out here Oh bill ball bag I
believe we blew their chemical weapon
plants up because they gassed little
kids okay
just a guess of what I read I think you
overly simplified it I think some kids
also died but if we're gonna start doing
that buddy if we're gonna start bombing
people because they gas people or bomb
people and killed little kids if
everybody who does that as a piece of
[ __ ] I don't know how well we come out
in the wash there pal just a guess from
what I've read but you're not allowed to
say that because if you do that means
you're in Isis you're not allowed to
criticize anything and be like what the
[ __ ] are we doing but I do understand
your fear of debt love the cast and your
work as unimportant as it may seem we
couldn't live without laughing peace
okay man you got your sundress on there
okay I understand that Syria okay what
they did was horrific Allah wronged but
you know should we have a lot more of
our ducks in a row before we start
police in the [ __ ] world is all I'm
saying you know what I mean if we're
gonna [ __ ] bomb those guys because
they gas little kids that sounds good
but you know at what point were they
gonna [ __ ] shoot some missiles that
the people who poison our food supply
that food supply that we're now trying
to sell around the
world and people like you're not
bringing that [ __ ] in our country do you
know this saying that about our food
like France and India Frances like
alright but you're gonna have to say
what's in it and we're like no we're not
we are there's no way we're gonna say
what's in our food how [ __ ] up is that
and I gotta try to navigate those waters
with my kid you know and there's no
explanation to it there's no we'll
listen man if you want to somehow make
300 people not starve to death you got
to cut some corners then I understand it
but there's there's nothing they're not
saying anything they're like shut the
[ __ ] up and eat it you know I don't know
the key of this world to making it is
you got to make so much money you could
donate to politicians campaigns and then
they just [ __ ] leave you alone and
you can do whatever you want like poison
the food supply of a country which if
I'm not mistaking is a terrorist act
when you then become an evildoer
dude I'm fat this is all [ __ ] you're not
allowed to see few you can say it about
anybody else but if you actually [ __ ]
have constructive criticism about your
own team you're immediately a conspiracy
theorist or you're a socialist
you know I don't understand the [ __ ]
that happened but it's brilliant PR I'm
so evidently I'm a communist right now
Oh Billy he's got a red beard I mean
it's alright they're probably jerks off
to Stalin's [ __ ] head shot every
morning now Derry want healthy food for
everyone in this country hey Bill no fun
hey Billy no fun love the podcast I'm a
fat guy totally agreeing with you fat
people blame everyone around them but
I'm one that knows that I shouldn't be
shoving cheeseburgers down my gullet
yeah dude and that's the power [ __ ]
choice right there if you start blaming
everybody else and all this other [ __ ]
outside he has to change as you keep
[ __ ] chow in this [ __ ] like granted I
don't have a psychology degree or even
know anything about nutrition as I trash
what's in our food supply you know you
know Kenny Rogers was the gambler I'm
the hypocrite
anyone anyway my question is do you
think it's worse to know that you're you
are ruining your life and eating like a
fat [ __ ] or pretending like it's a
thyroid problem or some excuse
anyways please come to the Bay Area I am
I'm doing a whole week of shows in May
up in San Francisco or Reno because I
missed you on the last one all right do
you think it's worse to know that you're
ruining your life and eating like a fat
[ __ ] or pretending like it's a thyroid
problem I think if you pretend like it's
a thyroid problem is a good way to go if
your apps if you had no power in this
situation like a lot of this [ __ ] that I
allude to you know like our food supply
like I'm powerless against that so it's
something I will joke about and then I
quickly don't think about it because I
don't know what to do you know you go
down to a farmers market those [ __ ]
have infiltrated down there too when you
start asking the [ __ ] hippie down
there hey so this is blah blah blah
where did this come from and they start
getting all [ __ ] shifty themselves
and then all of a sudden you feel like
you're an invasion of the body snatchers
you know so but I think the fact that
you're addressing that you're the one
shoving the cheeseburgers down your
gullet I have found that uh you know the
longest time I didn't think food was a
drug I totally believed it now and the
del Rey put me on this I guess it's a
gluten-free diet and I'm all this and I
barely have to work out you know and
quinoa is like this [ __ ] guy the food
that I eat on this diet
afterwards I don't feel like I gotta
take a nap I feel like energized you
know I feel like [ __ ] right now but I
don't know but I was taking a
multivitamin somebody [ __ ] all over that
go it doesn't matter enough of this
enough of that
you need to take this it's just like
that alright alright so I think it's
it's well look if you're not gonna do
anything about being a fat [ __ ] it's
gonna be more painful if you're just
gonna continue to be a fat [ __ ] not do
anything about it then I would lie
that's your thyroid problem you know
what I mean
you know that's like if you put out
something artistic and it doesn't do
well and then you blame the left or the
right or some [ __ ] like that like I've
seen with some movies and other [ __ ] you
can do that if you want it's not going
to help your next [ __ ] project
the project of you Navy training in
Australia you know Jesus Christ it's the
last [ __ ] place I would be in the
goddamn Navy is Australia but oh my god
what do you have to do to become a
[ __ ] Navy SEAL in Australia you have
to stab a great white shark to death
after they cut you a very making you
bleed before you get in the [ __ ]
water all right hey Bill just watched
that voice clip I think that voice clip
of you on YouTube about how you watch
the two weeks in hell thing I was in the
Australian Navy and it was similar but
you got [ __ ] for not keeping your own I
don't know if that means preface this is
before the media cared about all genders
we had Big Bertha which on the second
day of recruit school we were kept up
until 2 a.m. and were only allowed a
breakfast bar the night before they woke
us up by smashing trash cans in each of
our dorms right there I'd be out I'd be
out of the active [ __ ] this and I'd walk
out they'd be like good you're too weak
and I'd be like you're right I'm going
to a holiday and I want to thank all of
you for protecting me it may eight hours
sleep all right
that we had to run downstairs and carry
the rope called Big Bertha which was the
equivalent oh my god of the old ships
anchor lines and we ran for about 6
kilometers 3.7 miles what the [ __ ] until
we were allowed to have food after that
anyone that couldn't continue we were
partnered up with it had to carry them
and Big Bertha shaming the people that
couldn't continue I couldn't do that I
couldn't do
dude were they up on the rope weeping
did they literally get broken that bed
and we vent when we eventually got back
to base we were allowed breakfast and
then had to go on with the 8-hour drills
and fulfill our duty watches wow dude
that is some psychological breakdown
right there holy [ __ ] the most fucked-up
thing about all of this
hey wait dude did you make it through
all of this oh my god
juvie right they are difficult it is to
be me as your girlfriend ever said that
to you when you're thinking about that
Big Bertha much was this okay this was
in Oh two oh three and the Australian
Defence Force our military god forbid we
seem aggressive you say Defence Force
had instituted a policy where females
could only be treated or ordered for so
many hours a day so handing a v's -
gasps helicopter fuel so handling okay
helicopter fuel was only be performed by
men because it caused impotence and
women but also men but females could
hold positions on the yeah but they can
also make a baby they know anybody will
[ __ ] himself your dick and your balls
are expendable at that point that's
simple meth but females could hold
positions on the the helo refuel team
well that doesn't make sense but when it
came to actually handling fuel they get
volunteer males to do it after dealing
with [ __ ] like being blamed because my
ship couldn't get any new workers from
land because the ship was a [ __ ]
grinder and being in charge of people
when I haven't even been promoted I
decided to just start drinking so much I
got kicked off and it was my just best
decision ever this is like a great movie
spent my last year of my contract at a
base in a rich part of Sydney Australia
surfing in the morning and banging a few
of the new female sailors that all over
21 he put some parentheses that
ever been to see my proudest moment was
when I was awarded the humanitarian aid
medal because I build hospitals in
Sumatra after the old five tsunami I
spent days helping and building and the
people of Sumatra was some of the most
thankful and kindest people ever met a
lot of [ __ ] great story that is oh my
god can you imagine if you quit like how
tired you'd have to be how excruciating
Lee tired you have to be to climb up on
that rope and be carried back three
point seven miles I just have to go
mentally with every step this
humiliation is one step closer to being
over what do you say when you get off
good I might sorry about that yeah the
[ __ ] oh my god I can't imagine what
people said to you all the way back
overrated underrated all right overrated
New York and Los Angeles
I've lived in both cities for over four
years each I love them but I've also
lived on a creek in Virginia and a farm
in Vermont unless you need to be in one
of those cities just don't go there
I that I agree with that whole heart and
he should visit him
underrated Wayne's World I never heard
you talk about this movie you should
definitely watch this next time you take
a hit man all right I'll check it out I
will definitely check it out I had an
overrated underrated okay you know what
overrated these new [ __ ] elevators
where I got a [ __ ] hit like 20
goddamn buttons to let the elevator know
that I'm going to floor four so it can
[ __ ] compartmentalize all the people
there when I'm the only [ __ ] person
there you know then I got to take my key
out and [ __ ] run it over this skater
I like the old-school ones we just got
in you push the button first [ __ ] ten
years I was on the road that was that
was the way it was and I never had that
guy from no country from old men blow
out the lock on my door you know it was
completely fine I don't know what time I
stayed in a bed and breakfast
it [ __ ] Colorado with this dude from
Germany it was so [ __ ] creepy cuz he
was walking the halls at night and I was
just sitting there the hall light would
be on it I was looking at the light and
I didn't have a locker
did I think maybe I'd a skeleton key and
I was just sitting there oh I just
remembered my luggage had this ugly-ass
green like made out of cloth bag cloth
and plastic that this guy puked on one
side oh my god remember that Jay
described it through a lot of [ __ ]
people huh alright let's tell the German
would first so I'm [ __ ] I will tell
the puke one now you got a close with
the puke I've already told that story
and it's self [ __ ] gross I've been
puked on twice in my life once on my
head you know everybody in my family had
gotten sick and we had this bathroom was
a half a bathroom with no door you were
around the corner no privacy whatsoever
we lived in a duplex squirrels got into
the walls I had to scare him out then my
dad would kill him
you know mrs. 70s 80s you know [ __ ] like
that happened so there was no place to
make a facebook video and shame my
landlord it you know or my dad couldn't
do that you know so he just he had the
killer [ __ ] everybody the broom and I
was [ __ ] shaking it trying to get the
thing to come out and my dad was on the
other side here this giant [ __ ]
butcher knife or a metal bar or
something I can't remember and it was a
metal bar and that's what it was like a
big piece of lead or something and he
flushed that thing out and that [ __ ]
thing came running up the broom up the
broom handle
I remember its eyes were wide as [ __ ]
its tail was straight up in the end this
little brown qtpie [ __ ] red up my arm
and launched off of my shoulder I went
and then it ran into the half a bathroom
and then was one way it had only one way
out my dad was in the way and he [ __ ]
brought that let big down right on in
the back
it's [ __ ] neck and just slowly killed
the thing and I watched him do it so
anyways what time we were all [ __ ]
sick and I was in there finishing puking
in the bathroom with no door my brother
came running in and just ran and rather
than puking in the [ __ ] sink that was
readily available you know we were young
so it was just like you pee okay the
toilet and my head was obstructing the
toilet and it was like how low pressure
goes to high pressure takes the most
direct route which is right through the
airfoil and that's how you get lift when
you fly he used those same principles
when puke it into the toilet my head was
the airfoil and I've every [ __ ] puked
on my head and I just freaked out and I
was punching him as hard as I could in
the stomach as he was continuing to puke
but parents came in they were laughing
their ass off at me and the kitchen sink
was there she just [ __ ] dunked my
head in there [ __ ] washed it I was so
gross so gross so then the second time I
got puked on I was trying to save money
and I was taking a bus from Manhattan to
LaGuardia Airport we always said like
terminal I've taken the subway up to
Harlem and then took the bus over the
bridge and this dude just got up looking
all great and he [ __ ] projectile
vomited and he hit this sweet old lady
in front of me on her chest and it was
like the Kennedy assassination with the
spray just went back except it didn't go
to the left it went to the right where I
was sitting and it got on my foot my
sock and my lower pants and all over my
luggage
and then he just stumbled off the bus
and I was like you [ __ ] and I
wanted to beat the [ __ ] out of him but I
was broke and I needed the money and I
had to go to my gig I just glared at him
as all I could do and then I had to go
in there cut off
boss and now people look at me like I'm
an animal because I smell like [ __ ]
puke and I went into the bathroom like
beyond Tourette's took the sock off the
shoe off
[ __ ] but I didn't only had one pair
of footwear so I threw out the saw it's
disgusting I had to wash off my [ __ ]
pant leg the best I could my sneaker was
so good [ __ ] wet
I had one sock on one sock off walking
in a squishy wet [ __ ] sneaker and my
[ __ ] green cloth bag
I had wiped off all of the puke but it
was like stained and it had like the
little [ __ ] paper towel balls on it
it was so [ __ ] gross it was so
[ __ ] gross and I then had to get on
like a [ __ ] flight to like Minnesota
just sitting there smelling of stomach
acid and I I got off the plane and I
immediately went to a mall and I bought
some sweatpants and the cheapest [ __ ]
sneakers and socks and I just [ __ ]
threw the [ __ ] up and I bought a bag but
I didn't have time to do that before
which is about oh my god it was a
[ __ ] terrible trip I'm a [ __ ]
terrible trip down boys but you know
it's not as bad as what [ __ ] happen
on Southwest coulda been worse you know
that poor [ __ ] woman Jesus Christ see
that's the second time I've heard of
somebody getting sucked out like that
hearing that [ __ ] story that uh that
[ __ ] mechanic put the new windshield
in on the plane and they used the wrong
[ __ ] screws they weren't long enough
and they [ __ ] fly and like you know
they're cruising altitude so they got me
going for five hundred miles an hour and
the [ __ ] windshield flew off and the
captain got sucked out but his legs got
stuck on the yoke and he was outside the
[ __ ] plane and they were trying to
hold on to him and the door to the
cockpit got blown in the guy couldn't
slow down because it was on the
trolls they somehow the stewardess has
helped out you know the air pressure
I guess leveled off where they could
move a nut get sucked out and they were
trying to pull him in and they could one
of the stewardess could see the guy
outside the window looking at him he
wasn't blinking and she goes I think
he's dead we should let him go
fortunately they didn't they ended up
landing and it turned out the guy was in
shock [ __ ] nuts just sit there like
catatonic he got frostbite in one of his
eyes it was just and this is what kills
me is the [ __ ] maniac was flying
again
in a couple of weeks I think he still
flies I can't imagine you know what the
thing is is what they really should have
in the back of the plane is you should
also have those shoulder harnesses you
should have that you know when it goes
across your lap and then over your
shoulder so that if you sit next to the
[ __ ] window god forbid if the [ __ ]
thing blows out you still find but that
would be prohibitively expensive so I
guess what I'm saying is get the aisle
seat alright everybody
go Bruins and go Celtics and I don't
know I'm gonna go [ __ ] take a hot
shower and try to clear my goddamn
sinuses I'm gonna do another podcast
tomorrow I'll be all caught up alright
go [ __ ] yourself you can't sit I'll
check in on you tomorrow oh jeez